hat einer von euch Bock auf Duo mit mir
Fortnite ist also know Job ist einer von
euch am PC also irgendwer von euch wird
jetzt ausgewählt dann spielen wir
zusammen
oh nein oh nein
[Musik]
das ist ein Stream Sniper oder
nein es ist nicht
nein
hört ihr mich Jungs ja hallo was geht
jetzt sind wir zu dritt hier drin aber
wir können ja auch zu dritt zocken
eigentlich was ist mit Eric kannst du
auch was sagen
hallo
alles klar
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen schlechter als du
vielleicht ein bisschen schlechter als
ich Mist
oder nicht
ich heiße Luis okay
klasse wie alt ist man da
und du Luis wie alt bist du zusammen
bist du verloren mein Junge oder was auf
welche Schule geht ihr
Gymnasium
bekommen jetzt letztens auch ja warum
warum kriegt man jetzt gerade Zeugnisse
gekriegt
immer
okay
was habt ihr für ein Schnitt
und 2,3 krass
[Musik]
machen
ist Fortnite nicht erst ab 12
ja
[Musik]
hinter dir nein
ja der was
angefangen so ein bisschen was zu machen
[Musik]
was dazu
habe ich schon gefragt nee
du wolltest nicht sagen
sagen mal so zwei
wahrscheinlich ein schlechter
zweierschnitt ne nein nur zwei euch ein
Auto
[Musik]
deine lieblings Youtuber wenn guckst du
gerne
gar nicht
ein bisschen
drinne bleibt glaube ich
ich mache so primär eigentlich gerade
noch mein Studium
aber nebenbei bitte
[Musik]
gerade ab
nee
mache ich wirklich
schnell mit deinem Mann
da sind welche und dann komme ich an und
dann sind alle schon tot
junge ich kann nichts eintöten
du bist zu krank Alter ich mache gar
nichts ehrlich er sagt er ist schlecht
eigentlich ganz gut aber nur nicht bauen
eigentlich ziemlich Scheiben ja ich bin
eigentlich auch nur mit bauen wir nicht
relativ sehr sehr gut auch ja
unten steht auch noch eine Kiste das
heißt wir schauen mal was wir hier oh
mein Gott
[Musik]
geschossen wie die ganzen Mädel
aber gerade auch ziemlich weit weg
ist glaube ich gerade
da unten sind Gegner was mache ich denn
jetzt
[Musik]
ein habe ich
sterben wegen der Zone natürlich
schön
danke
tschüss
ich habe rasiert ich habe rasiert am
Ende
[Musik]